is our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer and a
warning her report contains flash
photography
as they roll out the red carpet for
Hollywood's great and good to Grace this
Sunday the academy Keen to hammer home
that after years of Oscar's so white
headlines who ends up here is changing
as next year it's much hyped new rules
kick in designed to improve diversity
with so many workarounds the qualifying
criteria even a film like All Quiet on
the Western Front top heavy with white
male Stars would still have little to
worry about
in fact in an exclusive interview with
Sky News the academy president revealed
all previous Best Picture nominees would
in fact still qualify we did find that
given these new guidelines all the past
nominations would have still qualified
but it was almost a way for people just
be a little bit more conscious about
those things
while Asian actors have a history of
four nominations this year there's zero
women up for best director
and only two black actors nominated
seemingly overlooked by the academy
phenomenal performances by both Danielle
deadweiler and Viola Davis there was a
lot of female artists and artists of
color working on that film we want to be
acknowledged for our skill for our
Excellence for our craft these are
people who've been out there for years
decades doing what they do
um and not getting noticed for the
female director behind the woman King
absent from this year's all-male lineup
something needs to give it's about a
systemic issue that's been there again
I'm really hoping that the Oscars take a
look at what bafta has done because the
changes have really worked and I think
that's what we need to do while actors
just want to see the best work get
employed it shouldn't just be about no
one's um Heritage or skin color but the
work also speaks for itself which
definitely raises some legit and genuine
questions thank you for all coming out
while the new rules might be well
intentioned it seems there's a lot more
work to be done if Hollywood is ever to
make real strides forward with equality
okay to Spencer Sky News in Hollywood